he is a doctor an ophthalmologist he's
also a junior teller he is I might say
the the one Republican who was willing
to go to places where Republicans don't
usually speak I admire him greatly for
that I want you to give him a warm
welcome Senator Rand Paul from Kentucky
hey senator
hey bill that applause that applause was
almost as good as Martin sharp or not
quite as much I don't know if you're
never gonna be no one's gonna be as
funny as Martin Short but I I want to
first congratulate you you were on the
cover of Time magazine a couple of weeks
ago show the cover there it says the
most interesting man in politics I guess
that's the Washington version of our
People magazine's sexiest man alive how
is it against your life well I think it
must be a low bar in politics to be the
most interesting I don't even think you
have to be very interesting to be the
most interesting person in politics so
how does you're exactly what true thanks
a lot for reaffirming that day but I
still think you are because you know
after the 2012 election the Republicans
kept saying they're gonna have to do
things to reach out to other than just
white men if they were ever gonna win
another national election you seem to be
the only one who got that memo among the
things you're doing is no it's true
among the things you're doing is restore
you want to restore voting rights to
felons which could which could increase
you know a turnout for Democrats how's
that going up well it could how's that
going over with your fellow Republicans
well you know the interesting thing
about it is is that we have two million
people who can't vote a friend of Mines
brother 30 years ago grew marijuana
plants in college and apparently he was
had a green thumb
and he was very good at it and he got a
felony conviction but he can't vote and
for thirty years he's had to mark off a
box on every application saying his
convicted felon and it's ruined his life
and I think of all these kids
particularly poor kids in our cities who
have no chance can afford bail get
pushed into bad deals there was a story
in The New Yorker about a month ago
about kalief Browder he was accused of a
crime he spent three years in Rikers
with no trial and then they finally
released him said oh our bad you know
we're not even going to charge you
anymore you're gone but he spent three
years in Rikers we've got a lot of
problems with criminal justice most of
it stems from the war on drugs though
well I admire you for that position
and you can stop referring to me as your
friend from college and my life wasn't
ruined by it okay was just sidetrack
alright so but I mean we're one reason
let's be honest we have so many
prisoners is because prison in this
country unlike most countries in the
world is a for-profit system do you
think your party is too cozy with
corporations Mitt Romney says
corporations or people are you on that
page well you know I think it's a
fiscally conservative thing to want less
people in prison particularly nonviolent
people because it's extraordinarily
expensive so let's imagine you have
somebody for a non-violent crime in jail
for 10 years and you say why don't we
reduce that to one year or six months
and let them get out on a work program
and maybe train them to work while
they're in for a short period of time if
we have to do that and then we would
save so much money so I think it's
frankly a fiscally conservative but it's
also the compassionate thing I think
kids make mistakes I made mistakes I
know you bill made a lot of mistakes you
deserve a second chance
you're completely correct about that
okay so let me let me ask you about the
big story this week which is I was just
referring to in the monologue which is
the big deal that the president made
with China to cap carbon now I know
you're from coal country Kentucky so
obviously this is a bit of a sticky
wicket for you but I just want to know
what your basic feeling is on climate
change because I know you're thinking of
running for president and in some states
you know you could get independence like
me I've said that I am available to the
Rand Paul campaign but not if I if I
don't think you're seeing this issue
realistically what is your view on it I
think the best way to do this is like
Bill I think you're fading out here I'm
not sure I can hear the question
no I'll get I'll give you the straight
I'll give you the straight poop on this
there's abundant evidence that carbon is
increasing and has increased since the
Industrial Age all I ask for is that the
solution has to be a balanced solution
and you have to account for jobs and
jobs lost by regulation and I'm not
against regulation I think the
environment has been cleaned up
dramatically through regulations on
emissions as well as clean water over
the last 40 or 50 years but I don't want
to shut down all forms of energy such
that thousands and thousands of people
lose jobs plus we're a growing
population and as we grow we need more
energy
and maybe cleaner energy will supplant
less clean energy over time and it
already is but I don't think that
shutting down dramatically one form of
energy is a good idea for an economy
well that sounds like you're pretty open
to renewable energy which is great
because you know when you use the job
excuse I mean the truth is that new
forms of technology create jobs not
destroy jobs wouldn't you agree with L
yeah and here's a here's a good example
of where I think we could work together
on it I have a new bill that's going to
be coming out in the next month or so
and it's going to be called the
deregulation of alternative fuels so I'm
for trying to get the government out of
the way of converting your trucks from
diesel to natural gas or from gasoline
to ethanol try to get the government out
there and let the marketplace take care
of this because some of these fuels are
actually cheaper too and if they're
cheaper then people will go for a
cheaper alternative that also is cleaner
for the environment so I think there are
ways that we can find a middle ground on
this but really it gets so far out there
and it does almost get there with a
religiosity that I don't think we need
to have and I think if we if we depict
this and oh my god me now you're losing
me I guess that's but but I want to be
honest with you bill if we think if we
if we're going to say the Statue of
Liberty's drowning
that's alarmist and we just can't we
can't get to we're not saying in a
minute now we're saying it could be
drowning in the future you know the
southern part of Florida want a lot of
people down there
and you might need Florida to win an
election
southern part of Florida is very worried
about being underwater they want to
secede from the northern part of Florida
which doesn't care about global warming
you might think about that for the next
election yeah and there's a lot of
middle ground on this and for example
like I think we ought to protect the
Ohio River the Clean Water Act says you
can't discharge pollutants into the
waters the navigable waters of the
country I fully support that but what's
happened over the last 40 years is
they've defined dirt and I'm not kidding
you clean dirt is defined as a pollutant
and my backyard is now a navigable river
some of us see that as oppressive and
they see that as getting in our backyard
and being a bully and putting people in
jail for putting clean dirt to raise the
elevation of their land what I want them
to protect the Everglades Ohio River the
Mississippi River the Atlantic Ocean the
Pacific Ocean but I don't want them in
my backyard turning leaves over and
saying hey there's some black on the
bottom of the leaves there for your
backyards a wetlands and we're going to
tell you what you can and can't do I
don't think that's the main part of this
issue but I will concede that point and
let's move on to the areas where I think
you and I have always been an agreement
which is ending the Empire and ending
the drug war I always admired your
father he was he was willing to get
booed by the base of his own party which
I think we all need to do to talk truth
to our own tribe and when it comes to
ending the Empire I mean you said if I
were president I would lay out the
reasoning of why Isis is a threat to our
national security and seek congressional
authorization to destroy Isis militarily
and that doesn't sound very polish to me
and the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
said we need 80,000 troops on the ground
to do that I thought I thought I could
count on you to be against troops on the
ground again e troops into Iraq and I
will oppose sending any of our people
back into Iraq it was a mess from the
beginning I would have voted against the
Iraq war we wasted a trillion dollars
and thousands of laws
and I would say if there's one thing I
would say if there's one thing that is a
truth that the other side has trouble
denying is that every time we have
toppled a secular dictator chaos has
ensued and radical Islam has become more
of a threat whether it was Iraq Libya
Syria Egypt every time it's gotten worse
through our intervention the reason why
I think it's a little bit different now
and I think Isis is worse because of her
involvement the Syrian civil war so I
voted against sending arms into the
Syrian civil war but why I've decided
now we have to do something is I think
that Isis is now a threat to our embassy
and to our consulate and I think we do
need to defend American interests and
there are lines that have occasionally
have to be drawn ok so last question you
said in 2000 the war on drugs is an
abysmal failure and a waste of money
are you still on that page I'm
absolutely there and I'll do everything
to end the war on drugs
the war on drugs the war on drugs has
become the most racially disparate
outcome that you have in the entire
country our prisons are full of black
and brown kids three-fourths of the
people in prison or black or brown and
white kids are using drugs bill as you
know are using drugs are using drugs at
the same rate as these other kids but
kids who have less means less money kids
who are in areas where the police are
patrolling police are given monetary
incentives to make arrests monitoring
system incentives for their own
department so I want to end the war on
drugs because it's wrong for everybody
but particularly because poor people are
caught up in this and their lives are
ruined by it music to my ears Thank You
Senator Paul I think it's only a good
thing for America when I'm not sure who
I'm gonna vote for next time thank you
Rand Paul everybody